i imagine you have these these grandiose
ideas and this this concept that you
have yeah and there's a guy there that
is like i am here to scale you back down
yeah
like you're pushing the envelope a
little bit aren't you like it's like i
want to record on the moon
only a dying black hole like a black
hole is like the loudest sound ever the
moon would be nice but i don't think i'm
gonna
lads lads lads welcome back to another
episode of the trash taste podcast i'm
lad number one and i'm with lad number
two and three as always and i've got a
lad sitting next to me who are you
uh just a lad right i'm just some
[ __ ] guy
there's some movie we just found in
australian games yeah
i was i was like i thought i was the
only one no not today not today so uh
after many many months many many moons
we finally have the one and only mr
kevin penkin on the show
aside from being and i was just an
aussie lad what else are you known for
yeah not much mate
[Laughter]
no okay so i guess like on a good day i
write music for anime games um uh some
of those on a good day
on a bad day i'm just some [ __ ] guy
on the couch drinking a beer and
watching youtube
but uh
hey actually yes it's not a bad day
actually yeah
on a professional day i am writing music
for um anime video games as i said uh
some of those being made in abyss
and tower of god and rosie with shield
hero and also did star wars visions one
of the episodes of star wars visions
which oh yeah not the worst thing to
happen to
i guess me
[Laughter]
composed modest composers for star wars
not the worst thing to happen not the
worst not
i think the thing that is like always
like i've never asked you this i'm just
like how the hell did this happen
yeah
yeah because it seems like japanese
anime would want to get japanese
composers so like how did this all come
around and i guess they have for the
longest time right yeah yeah what's your
like background with no sure i mean
well it's i mean it's a very super
random like kind of series of events
that like i don't really understand how
it happened i'm happy it did but i have
no idea actually how it happened but i i
guess like the the chronological events
is that i actually started working uh
probably yeah the in the end of my teens
i started working with the final fantasy
composer
wow yeah which is awesome
how did that happen
okay sorry let's go back like no one
just like works with nobody you know
conception yeah
so yeah i
had always like wanted to do like video
game music um i remember because i
i uh my first game console um was
gamecube and i played this game called
metroid prime which is still my favorite
game amazing game right right yeah it is
one of my favorites um and uh when i
played the game i was like i want to do
that
and so that's basically what happened i
was like oh i want to do that one yeah
right and so
uh i kind of just like started you know
pretending to write video game music and
um australia also had a bunch of like
video game concerts that happened
including the final fantasy concerts
yeah uh but uh
in a slightly different did you just
burp no
i thought i had this click
did you interrupt my story no no i came
dead
i [ __ ] up
um so yeah australia had all these um
kind of concerts going on i met a
conductor called arnie roth uh who did
um some concerts called play and so i
went over from perth western australia
from where i'm from uh went over to
sydney to do this um to kind of view
this um
this concert and uh he invited me to
come say hello to him and also one of
the composers there who's here on hill
composer akira yamakos i met him right
that was really cool and he was like
super kind of he was very very generous
with his time for like some eager you
know piece of [ __ ] 15 year old yeah i
really appreciate that even to this day
but um uh because i met annie when i saw
that um was going to come to a concert
in seattle yeah
i was like hey so we might come over
like me and my dad might come over and
come say hi right yeah and um they were
like oh well thank you for coming such a
long way from perth which is like 36
hours in a plane right i'd recommend
that by the way yeah uh but yeah certain
like 36 hours go to seattle um met any
and then he was like oh let's come to
the dress rehearsal and come say hi as
well to toyamatsu and stuff wow so yeah
so you're just going to these concerts
we went to that one yeah right did you
say hi well because we met at that
previous one
um yeah it was very very lucky yeah you
make it sound very easy like yeah like
so you met him initially and you just
bumped into him initially or you're like
no no so like we had been invited to
come say hi at this concert in sydney
which then led to this concert in
seattle where my son was where we met
for the first time right right right and
um australia all the um school um sort
of all the school years are flipped
because it's summer right okay so
because it's
and so that's when we have like the at
the classic school like two three months
kind of breaks right right right
basically all of december and january is
just off yeah
yeah okay yeah but uh but um that was
obviously like new year's and stuff and
christmas in japan so yeah for summer
holiday we would go to
winter in japan right end up very
graciously say hello yeah you can come
say hi and stuff and yeah eventually
just that just led to a couple of um
yeah it's like small it's not the final
fantasy game i should be very clear
about it right right but um yeah i was
yeah but you made some pretty insane
connections from that i i yeah i mean
it's still pretty crazy to talk about
but yeah you make it sound so easy like
yeah oh you just had them on speed dial
yeah
i just went to a concert and then just
went to another concert and then just
you know things happen and then uh
yeah here i am honestly at the end of
the day i'm just i'm just happy it
happened i mean i know i've been using
that word a little bit too yeah it's
like yeah i'm just super just
things have just yeah panned out
not so [ __ ] i love right i'm trying to
piece the whole thing in my head
together like yeah me too
how it all comes together yeah so you
met him again at another concert yeah
how did that translate into then working
for them because surely that's a massive
leap well we had because of these
japanese trips that i would do over
australian summer japanese winter yeah
what happened is we were able to um just
kind of keep a connection and then
eventually like i kept on submitting
some cds and stuff like that right
so right in this case it worked out but
you know it's like i you never think
about it that way you're just hoping the
best to just you know just be involved
in some ways yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it
feels nice so you just like kept
submitting you're working like i'm not
like okay okay i mean more like couple
lessons they actually you know listen to
it yeah yeah yeah no obligation i would
not hold it against them did not do it
but yeah so graciously kind of did and
yeah eventually um i'm happy to say that
i was able to be useful to them so
so so you were like making music from
like as early as like how old like oh
[ __ ] um like i i assume very very young
right like were you like classically
trained and stuff or yeah so i played
flute i came from fluke
just see see you're playing fluent which
is such a funny history
i can do the um i can do the anchorman
certainly oh really yeah i can do it i'm
like
why didn't you bring your flute yeah
yeah
sorry i left it in there i left it in
melbourne
nice um i actually like picked it up a
little bit uh last year
like during the pandemic so i was like
oh it's [ __ ] bored now so yeah yeah
yeah try it again and ended up using it
a bit on the the new shield here and
stuff so i did something right right yes
wow yeah you stuck that in hell yeah
cheeky jazz flute
so you started with flute from like uh
really yeah and then you kind of just
went on from there yeah flew playing
play metroid prime wanted to write music
like played on i'm not sure if you know
finale yeah yeah yeah
for a little while and like didn't
understand what like working with actual
like you know daws and stuff yeah which
are digital audiences workstations yeah
yeah logic pro and stuff like that yeah
yeah um and logic pro is eventually what
i moved to and still use it today
yeah
it's very overwhelming when you look at
it yeah
i know nothing about audio i i i'm that
guy dude
i'm like the connor of this episode i'm
like yeah that's uh that's letters that
you were saying right now i know more
well um i said but connor was kind of
right with the whole beefs and boosting
a little bit oh oh
we're getting into that already
i know i hate to say but i like the
noise is the most accurate way to
describe how i feel about music as well
you're a you're a literal musician
you do this for a living oh my god oh
yeah my life has been alive dude like i
remember i remember when conor first
brought up the whole like beeps and boop
[ __ ] i was like don't worry eventually
when we get kevin he'll be on my side
well i won't lie i like opened a bottle
of gin and just started drinking after
that
what the [ __ ] are you guys talking about
at the same time i was like to be honest
like yeah maybe we'll go into like a
little bit more detail about why the
noise is nice but they're not yeah the
noise is nice yeah i mean that's yeah
that's yeah it's just like i like the
the things my ear is feeling you know i
like hearing them
yeah it's just soothing but we should
explore why we should explore why
what why why why why why though
that's that's like that's the level that
he's never crossed before
i don't know is it i feel like it's the
most primitive way of experiencing music
like the way that it was just meant like
is there any other
music because
everyone had this kind of like deep art
meaning and i'm like noise is nice you
know like it's just kind of like i don't
listen to a piece of music and feel any
emotion yeah i just take it in and i'm
like this no i mean we all do but we
also it's that plus alpha for us you
know like you know it's not just the
alpha all right like yeah best way to
maybe describe it's like okay so noise
is nice but it's the the noise is nice
because like certain things that are
working together right right right said
nice nice yeah yeah this is what i
brought you on today to explain this
concept
it's the most monkey way possible not a
stupid way like i would expect yeah yeah
well i mean because like it's just made
up of like random kind of what's the
word i guess sort of category so it's
like you've got melody you've got
harmony you've got rhythm and stuff like
that texture texture is really really
important so texture is like what what
is texture texture is
the sound quality the sound quality the
quality of a sound that's like that's
like
you sounding like an alien right now i
was like
what does this texture you humans speak
of
i don't normally talk to musicians and
normally when i hear someone talk about
texture it's with like food or like with
things that you feel like your hands you
can't touch
the same thing yeah the exact same
concept it's like okay uh [ __ ] okay
okay you know the um
i think it's billy gene you know that
yeah
yeah okay the drums yeah the drum sound
is super distinctive yeah because it's
tech because anyone can play that beat
and anyone can play that like a drum
like that right why does it sound why do
you know that it's that [ __ ] song
straight away because the sound of the
drum the textual quality
specific and unique right so that's the
whole idea of texture like texture i
think is criminally not criminally and i
can't pronounce it [ __ ] word right
now but
primitively yeah primitively underrated
um no texture is like like i guess i
would call it like kind of the secret
ingredient oh even though it's not a
secret and you know it's it's it's the
spice that you add to make it all come
together right right that's right
there's many spices yeah
i i see like we've inadvertently like
separated the musicians on one side and
like
the apes on the other side it's got like
a glass panel here
don't [ __ ] come near it
yeah okay
we talk about anime yeah yeah i get it i
get it okay so you started you know
doing you know writing music from a
young age you met nobody so like how did
you then go from like that to oh now i'm
writing music for main abuse
because like i feel again that's like
not like one-step process yeah uh there
were there were a couple of steps so so
okay number one how did you learn
japanese because i i assume you would
need to learn japanese to work in the
yeah yeah yeah i mean obviously i'm not
yeah i'm not i'm not this beautiful boy
when it comes to that but you know i i
feel like i do fine uh yeah yeah yeah i
feel like i do well and um so
yeah i learned japanese in australia
there's this thing called tafe which is
sort of a
like community college yeah i think it's
like like like sort of a yeah
not not universal you almost you can
trade as like a pre-college almost at
some point yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like
certificate level stuff so
bachelor certificate right sort of
underneath that yeah so uh i did that um
because i went to school at the west
australian academy of performing arts
whopper as it's called yeah
um so i went to i went to whopper for
three years doing composition there yeah
and i was in perth but then um at night
time i was remember i remember i'm
trying to imagine me doing this now like
going to school during the day and yeah
go to scratch
and not have that energy
[Applause]
i can't even use the jet lag excuse
anymore
oh wow no so i went to this tafe school
thursday and a uh
wow let's try that again tuesday and
thursday yeah tuesday and thursday and
on the middle day the wednesday i would
go with all the classmates that i um
that like i was learning with and we're
gonna go to this seedy [ __ ] bar in
northbridge which is like kind of like
the uh i don't know even how to describe
it it's the uh
city part of the park it is it is the
like club crazy like cd you know um
[Laughter]
one pattern that i've seen from every
australian i met from perth is that they
do not know they no longer live in perth
yeah i know i know four
people yeah including you who are born
and raised in perth who are no longer
impossible yeah
so like i i do i would say that if
you've grown up there there is like a
certain like i want to call it shout out
to our phantom
look there is a certain like jovial sort
of jokey aspect to like saying oh yeah
i'm from perth [ __ ] what yeah yeah
but like once you leave i think there is
like a little bit of homesickness like i
[Music]
it so we went to this bar
in northbridge because perth is super
super popular with working holiday
japanese people oh really super popular
oh i didn't all know that people love
coming to perth and that's great and it
is it is what it's worth even though i
just like kind of described like
something obviously
i'm trying to wrap my head around what
the reason that might
joey like i've never seen that facial
expression in joe where he tried to
understand either his japanese side or
his australian side and he's just like
there is something that's gone wrong
both my australian japanese side were
like that sounds like a lie
[Laughter]
as far as i can remember it's not but
i wonder why though i i i want to see
sun
sun and beaches right yeah
lots of wine
yeah they don't come to the uk huh uh
people in london
yeah
not really of course like it's also very
far away but i guess so is australia now
that i think yeah earth's pretty [ __ ]
far away yeah i mean like nothing yeah
yeah yeah that's true the connection
between there is a connection between
australia and japan
and there's quite a lot of sister cities
and stuff
right and obviously it's like sort of
the australasia region so yeah that's
triggering for y'all yeah
but um no the australasia region is um
obviously yeah i think there's there's a
lot of i mean pre-code of course there
was a lot of like kind of travel
treaties and stuff like that yeah yeah
yeah working holiday visas were like
rampant yeah like a better word
definitely yeah um but we would go to
this bar and all the working holiday
people because it was a shitty bar but
on a wednesday night it would be
international night
10 jugs and which is like i think like
seven pound like 8.5 american dollars
right and uh yeah you just get [ __ ]
wasted with uh awesome like working
holiday japanese people and because
obviously when you're a bit toasted your
your language confidence yeah right of
course of course somehow it just raises
up yeah yeah okay that's working
yeah okay let's go yeah yeah
yeah and um so you would almost have
like the two formal training days on
each side and then you have like the the
the real training day the toaster
that's how it started and then actually
like since
since covid we've been doing a lot more
like kind of business meetings and stuff
on zoom and stuff and so like my keigo
has like gone way through the roof now
because it's almost like how i almost
exclusively speak like sort of with that
or like almost like i always treat it as
like a buffer it almost feels like a
buffer if like if you're not right if
you're not like not sure how to speak to
someone using the kegel almost feels
like i'm just like
i'm just like
right i did notice that actually because
like uh a couple was it a couple months
ago that we did the main abyss event
yeah yeah like because so i i did like
co-host like a maiden abyss event for me
and abyss too and obviously kevin wasn't
there like in person but he was on like
a zoom call because that was like a
segment where we were talking about the
music for the show and you know
obviously because it's a japanese event
live stream to a japanese audience yeah
kevin had to speak japanese for the
entire part yeah and uh you know i
hadn't heard kevin speak japanese in a
while so i was like oh you know
hopefully you know he'll he'll get
through it yeah and i was like damn he's
kegeling the [ __ ] god i was like
he's like way too polite
in this entire thing he's like he's like
talking to the [ __ ] prime minister
levels i'm like
he's just talking about like the music
it's like
the problem is because i i i've almost
like lost the middle ground now so it's
like right way too casual oh it's way
too formal right right and i was like
just think because it's like something
something something instead of saying
like yes or something i'm just like desk
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's just like you in a nutshell right
because like you once one thing you'll
you'll realize meeting kevin is like
he's like the most humble and nice
person like you've ever met you know
um but then that that is until like he
starts getting like a few pints in him
yeah i'm like i can always like you can
always track how drunk kevin and kevin
is by how much more australian he is so
at the beginning of the life at the
beginning of the night you're like you
might not even know that he's australian
or anything like he's like
people like kevin is either extremely
professional or extremely unprofessional
there's no there's no middle
that doesn't sound what you're talking
about
[Laughter]
i definitely experienced that this
weekend right because you know obviously
like during the convention you know we'd
go out and have a couple of drinks and
all that kind of stuff right and it's
like uh you know that that uh
that friday night where uh we're out you
know drinking and uh we got that burger
king at like two in the morning yeah man
bringing that up
you want that to be committed to youtube
yeah
because like you know god was saying
like you know you know kevin is drunk
because he just gets like exponentially
australian right and i think that burger
king night was the most aussie i've ever
heard kevin i was so bitter about that
it [ __ ] sucked it was so shitty
that's burger king yeah i know but like
there was like a pot like first it was
[ __ ] 2 30 in the morning
there's
so to explain it's like it's like 2 30
in the morning obviously everyone's like
drunk and you know everyone's trying to
get the a little bit hungry right yeah
so there's a burger king there and kevin
comes out with like a bag full of what
he thinks is like just a light snack
right
when he pulls out of the bag
it's like the fattest double whopper
that i've ever seen in my life he pulls
it out of the bag and he's like in the
most australian way he's like what the
[ __ ] is this
and he's like oh [ __ ] it i've already
bought it it's whatever so just like
this just like goes back to like the
[ __ ] izakaya thing where i ordered
too much can i just [ __ ] hit button
just hit the button oh my god
you're like you're like this is an
amazing idea
i can handle all that so so do you
explain that ambition last time we went
out uh to japan we we
we went to an izakaya and then kevin was
like pretty hungry you know we we we
started drinking before but kevin was
like we were [ __ ] tired yeah yeah we
we we were hungry but we also like just
a little bit tipsy and kevin thinks
thanks you know what's a good idea if i
order one of everything on the menu
it's a four-page menu
it's four pages of menu for just the
chicken
was like full page of menu for like the
pork it was like an onslaught it did not
stop yeah i've never had to like because
there's a it's a [ __ ] all you can eat
like you can just do it but yeah at the
same time i was like yeah we had like i
was like i had to talk to the [ __ ]
staff member like can you stop can you
can you stop
food that you have not physically yet
stop it
because it was like there was like 15
different livers and i'm like how do you
even find this many livers i'm just i'm
done i'm going to assault this shield
if we go to an izakaya and there's a
tablet there we can order never never
give it to kevin yeah he's just like oh
what does everyone want and everyone's
just like oh just just whatever and
kevin takes that too literally as
everything well
because you know i think it's just
because like you know i haven't been
back home to australia in a while all
right and then like you know i have a
couple of mates in australia who are
like very very awkward but like you know
kevin is like next level strength
especially when he's drunk so he was
like
so
yeah so like you know going back it's
like he like unwraps the double waffle
right because he's like he's already has
it in his hand he takes like three bites
out of it and he just goes this [ __ ]
this is so [ __ ]
i think i
it was so dry and it was so heavy yeah
it was like oh i [ __ ] up okay
i [ __ ] because like in australia we
don't have bird kid
jacks
yeah yeah so it's like you know if
burger king was like better it's good
it's funny yeah like hungry jax is like
i would argue way way better than
yeah but like but not by much
not by much to be fit sorry no no i
don't know if i'm crazy but i swear
burger king don't they like drench it in
like sauce
so [ __ ] dry right like the burger is
like the most like
skeleton-esque burger
yeah like extremely anemic yeah i i had
the snap the patty in half yeah i had
the chicken like uh like that was like a
long chicken burger type of thing and uh
and it was like it was so it was like
freeze-dried it was so [ __ ] dry i was
like
yeah yeah
yeah bad tactical error yeah
yeah but it's just so hilarious just
kevin raging at a double whopper
at 2 30 in the morning i've got a good
friend back home i remember because i
took him to this like really like
there's this ankara bakery thing on it's
called beaufort street in um
yeah there's a place there's a there's
an ankara bakery on beaufort street in
mount lolli
street
sorry i'm a child all right all of our
eyes just like clean like
i'm gonna blame the uh that's the dry
london air oh yeah not very successful
in perth and like they do like really
good baths they're [ __ ] amazing
my friend was not a fan of them i
remember because he
took he said the same thing and he tried
to throw it out and he and it exploded
all over his car
so this egg just [ __ ] went all over
his body
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah but there is like yeah there's
food rage there's there's a lot of
foreign
[Laughter]
oh my god
oh my god music yeah
what do you call like a track and shield
here just like dry chicken salad
going like more like psycho with the
naming convention yeah recently so that
might i'm waiting for double whopper at
2 a.m
the names only appear like they're
soundtracks right yeah the show arrives
you can just make no i mean if you're
doing like an ip or an ed they do have
the opening yeah
[Laughter]
uh i didn't notice uh in some of your
tracks in shield hero like i think the
first shield there was there were like
some weird names in here yeah actually
i'm gonna get out now because they were
like they were like some some of like
the usual suspect names of you know like
generic anime music names and then there
was just so so you go through this
soundtrack list and most of them are
like you know normal you know you have a
track that's called the rising of the
shield hero of course the titular title
of course you know you have like some
you know isekai type lists type track
called like game start and stuff like
that and then you go down to like near
the bottom and then there's a track
called like spirit bomb i'm like huh
that that was that like a cheap dragon
ball z reference probably is it's kevin
okay we can we can we can get away with
that we can get away with that and then
then you're just like boom boom boom
you're like kevin are you kind of
running out of names are you gonna hand
it even further and then you just
there's a track just called noms
i listen to the track and i'm just like
this this name has nothing to do with
the track at all and then you go next
it's like matty boy
boy
who's
right
[Music]
yeah
no no because like when when they
finally like shoot down kim jong-un in
the movie yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] franco's character just goes
like it fires a tank bullet into the
helicopter and that's the reference
it was like 50 plus tracks yeah that one
yeah how many
that seems like
excessive almost it well i mean because
it was 26 it was 25 or 26 episodes so
that that required so basically
as um as i'm sure you all know but just
for kyrie and all that sort of thing
yeah there's normally cause so one core
two courses yeah yeah yeah yeah
so
like a season kind of oh so one core is
12 for 13 episodes
like 24. okay okay so something along
that length and so uh for example bend
this is well then this season one of
course is uh like
13 episodes so it's one chord right
right shield hero had 26 episodes
yeah so normally for two cores you kind
of you don't double the music but you
probably like 1.5 times it right so um
for men this um the um
the the the season one i think the
soundtrack comes in at one hour and 52
minutes something like that right and i
think it's about
i think that was actually about 50
something tracks so like maybe 40 mid 43
but then shield hero yeah it was about
60 62 tracks and it's about two hours
and 50 minutes of music and is that like
left up to you do you decide how many
tracks you're making actually they're
like hey we need 62 tracks make them all
sound it's actually pretty specific so
what basically happens is when you get
commissioned to write anime music you
get a just basically a massive excel
sheet called the called the music order
yeah so when you're the music order it's
basically yeah just like you'll have
like m1 like music one and then it'll
say like main theme and then yeah m2
would be like main theme happy version
like m3 will be main theme dark version
yeah right right
main theme hero version or something
like yeah yeah yeah yeah
quite generic sort of like descriptions
and they might have some explanation or
they might have some you know some
visual images and stuff like that so you
actually get a lot of freedom which i
really really like yeah so if you think
about how like because they'll they'll
have all that sort of thing there maybe
once you get to like m20 would be like
battle one speed battle or like battle
two like seriously
seriously sometimes i mean we can get
very specific as well but like it'll
start from that sort of like slightly
more abstract sort of approach which is
actually really really cool because that
way you you actually do have a lot of
kind of
like i said freedom to actually just
trying to explore different ideas right
just like like you get the freedom to
call attract norms yeah
i guess the track doesn't really matter
right because because we when you're
writing it um this has changed like my
process on this has changed like a
little bit since shield here in italy so
i probably wouldn't do that again but
yeah
it was that was a process hey you know
eventually
well um so um
when you're writing uh what what i like
to do is try and um match a lot of like
sort of the textual stuff i was talking
about earlier yeah i love trying to
match texture to the actual visual uh
sort of um palette if you will
um best way like one of the most sort of
like sort of basic examples of classic
examples i can give is uh in maine abyss
obviously like it's quite a small amount
of like kind of kid characters going
into like huge like cavernous abyss yeah
explore and also you see in the visuals
it's not there's normally a lot of wide
shots where you just see kind of the the
sport yeah yeah yeah it just goes like
super fast
and so like the idea of trying to
actually depict that visual sort of
stimuli music is is quite appealing to
me it's sort of um yeah almost like a
it's called like word painting uh which
is basically like let's say you have
lyrics and say i'm going to rise up and
then the melody goes i am going to rise
up it's like it's like literally rising
with them
actually because in the main theme it
like the the violence that part of the
star does actually rise up and like
again it's like okay it sounds so basic
but it is good fun yeah a lot of
a lot of the like court stuff in maine
abyss also likes all that dissension so
you hear a lot of like
normally it's going it's still only
going down or up but like yeah yeah like
the whole idea of like things rising and
falling as much as possible so yeah like
one one thing i've always wanted is
pretty much how you how you like blew up
onto the scene because i think like you
blew up immediately
um in terms of like sound in terms of
being a composer which is like i i find
it's really rare but i think a big part
of that was just that opening scene in
made in abyss
where it was just like the instrumental
with like the vocals as well and it was
just no dialogue it was just like a
montage just using using this opening
track and it just like immediately it
not only did it sell you on the show but
it just like put your work onto the map
like how did that come about was that
planned or was that just like a happy
coincidence um i was like totally lucky
and i'm glad i was um like almost
because i i had a different track i had
a much more subtle track in mind for
that right um
uh called um swings and roundabouts that
was like kind of my original idea for
that thing so it was it was supposed to
be like oh let's do these nice kind of
really cool textures and stuff as that's
like kind of coming over but then the
sound director um and the director
decided differently to kind of because
they you you don't write these unless
it's a movie or it's a specific scene
that's been requested to be written
synchronize the picture yeah all the
music is written what's called free
right then then it's synced later
oh yeah so that that wasn't meant to be
synced absolutely originally the like my
like vision of it was to be different
but um uh the director and the um the
director and the sound director
obviously had a pretty deep discussion
they decided to to put that song there
and even better they decided to put it
there with minimal dialogue and sound
effects which yeah ridiculously like
lucky yeah and so just to you know i
guess just to like
how to how to even explain this
to see that happen and to be so happily
wrong
right like what my vision was yeah yeah
everything else to say oh man thank god
people are smarter than me
but um like because that song the song
was written just as sort of an uh kind
of almost just like another like trying
to make another palette for the for the
soundtrack because when you start it
you're just kind of going through like
point after point after point it's like
okay well let's just try and write a
piece of music based off this manga
panel yeah write a piece of music based
off this description or this idea you
know obviously like reading through the
the content yeah stuff
so i was thinking like oh yeah they must
what do they give you i'm like oh yeah
you can just go to the manga most of the
time right yeah yeah yeah mango or in
tower you got manga
and so just
when when when you're able to like kind
of look at what is essentially you can
just see the entire story kind of pan
out obviously you're given like anime
specific materials as well which is
super helpful
but um yeah
when you're just trying to find
something that actually kind of
hopefully
like
what's the best word respects the
content as well yeah yeah
um you know you're kind of creating
you you're adding an audio element that
was not there before yeah as the mega
might be there before so there might be
reference that you know people might be
able to reference the anime to the manga
yeah okay well this is similar this is
different something like that right
music ever existed so yeah
um it's both freeing and also kind of
terrifying to yeah you know potentially
yeah that's the same because like when i
saw that scene i was like this is so
perfect for this opening scene it must
have been like specifically made for
this one scene right it was made around
it was made around like scenes like that
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i would almost
describe it more as like it was almost
an impression of the show itself yeah
did you did you feel like because that
was your first was that your first anime
work no sir it was uh that's what jesus
map that was my third
yeah
okay oh wow all right wow okay so now
the first one was uh it's always the
same company kingdom of citrus but uh
right did
actually it was a video game and it's
actually a video game i did with uimatsu
like way back when so
okay
for this game called nor knight
a couple years later when i started
doing anime for this company called
kenneman citrus they said we're actually
doing an anime of nor 9 as well right
and so that i i did so you were like the
natural picture yeah maybe that was it
yeah maybe that was it because i mean i
guess i guess you know it makes sense to
get the guy who did the game yeah yeah
yeah yeah so
yeah yeah i didn't think about it
is that not obvious no uh
yeah absorbs
at the same time maybe this is why i
didn't think about it i was also doing
something called under the dog which was
a
kickstarter oh
kickstart overview and that was that
came first and so yeah i didn't know
like how everything kind of progressed
but um i was on that for the trailer
music and then they asked if i wanted to
do the actual soundtrack yeah that was
so cool because that was like the that
was the first one that was i was like oh
wow i had no idea i was like well happy
about that yeah yeah i've been like you
know just [ __ ] i feel like a better
word fantasizing about [ __ ] trying to
do anime for yeah yeah yeah lucky enough
to do games for a couple of years yeah
yeah oh my god
so happy about that yeah i was in
college and just finished college in
london so i was living here at the time
i had no idea what was going to happen
boom like
like we were now you're an anime yeah
yeah yeah
yeah you were composing for games while
in college yeah so when i did um i was
when i was doing undergrad that's when i
started doing lots of stuff and then
that develops with other games both uh
japanese and so you were busy
yeah yeah i think i don't know how i did
it because i i mean again maybe maybe
we'll get to the bottom of this while
talking to you yeah you obviously got
traffic i'll make another five-head
observation
this is like just like like like therapy
times three
therapists times three it's like oh my
god everything makes sense it's all
connected man it's all connected
dude um
yeah so i was working throughout college
as well um and yeah just
i
it just happened i mean i was just
working names work work work work work
and just you know
just fell over and just happened
out those compliments straight away son
okay so like now what i want to know
actually is like how you and god got to
know each other because like i kind of i
kind of met you guys through that right
like i made you through gone and whatnot
um so like it's like
where was the connection there uh that
that's a pretty simple connection i hope
you remember
like a pre-story okay so it connects to
that right that's right um so i i think
i might have like strongly mentioned
this to sydney or something potentially
but i haven't i don't think i've
mentioned it to any of you at least i
don't remember mentioning it um so i
actually like when i was like going
through like college and stuff i like
totally felt out of anime right right
not watching it like i remember when i
was watching all the ghibli stuff and
whatnot and some shows like some really
important shows for me like kind of just
to get into
anime kind of fandom to begin with when
i was like 14 or so then okay well out
of it kind of went totally on the ground
for a long time
and then what brought me back was doing
maiden abyss
because uh i was like you know it's like
one of those shows where like creatively
was the first time i felt like oh i'm
actually doing music that really feels
like me sort of thing yeah yeah
i feel like i'm bringing like a lot of
this sort of more experimental stuff
that i've learned in um primary school
in undergrad yeah yeah yeah like masters
in london and then that and that was
sort of like honed like film music craft
right right what was your degree in
sorry i did a bachelor of composition of
music technology at west australian
academy of performing arts and then i
did a masters of music for screen
composition screen wow at royal college
music in london oh yeah yeah
no no we
don't drop
[Laughter]
i mean they it really kind of like honed
the craft that's why there's like yeah
and just like learned how to like
produce music for film yeah so yeah but
uh what whopper like focused a lot more
on experimental music or new music uh a
lot of arts art music
when you said waffle i thought you were
talking about
burger king
i was on a beach just eating a bunch of
whoppers experiments with music
sounds pretty accurate
um
ah like it just kind of all came
together for this like yeah this project
right yeah yeah i mean god bless
citrus man they just gave me so much so
much freedom
yeah yeah yeah yeah kind of birth to
just kind of actually just kind of try
some things that yeah i didn't know i
could do it and i felt really good
actually just kind of going through that
process of yeah well i can i can oh i
remembered like that violin technique
i've never like tried before and
oh i can try and like record in this
giant space in vienna that like yeah can
try and mimic like the the size of the
abyss sort of thing yeah yeah trying
those techniques that like were just
introduced to me either through
undergrad or post grad right it was just
really nice yeah yeah
yeah yeah um what was the question
how are you in garment oh yeah
sorry there is a point to all this
point okay so
on the back of those feel goods you know
doing events yeah um i was curious okay
how is the show doing yeah right and i
would type in in you know the you google
yourself google no no no i googled
making this okay
okay is it you know how is it you know
yeah yeah i think and all these youtuber
guys were most fun to talk about i'm
like oh okay they're talking about it
and they're liking it and then um
you made this video yeah about like
which
music
what was your favorite anime and what
i think was like one of like the anime
of the year kind of thing yeah
oh like i you know you had like the art
category and the animation category yeah
the music category yeah and he made this
like great joke like about the fact that
i was aussie
there was there was this one clip that
got posted in like the behind the scenes
documentary of made an abyss all right
because it's like very professionally
made documentary and there's just this
one clip of kevin going to be like he he
was talking to someone yeah and i i
can't remember the exact line but he
talks about oh yeah can uh uh this he's
like you you you refer to someone as
like a mate or something like that right
yeah so yeah yeah yeah yeah so
um dimitri was the guy i was doing right
he's he's uh amazing he's he's like the
main violinist and all the abyss right
he is like the bosses of bosses when it
comes right right right unbelievable his
big dude boys yeah yeah yeah he's like
trying was good sorry i don't do a good
impression of him
we don't
because i don't play violin and play
flute yeah so i checked with college
friends before going over i'd be like is
this [ __ ] this is [ __ ] up if i give
this to someone in a recording studio
yeah it's obviously remember like when
you go into a recording session that's
[ __ ] thousands of euros or dollars
whatever it is like a [ __ ] hour like
yeah
like five figures easily in a couple of
hours yeah like or eight hours some
depending on how many people you're
hiring yeah yeah super expensive
scenario to be like oh the flute player
wrote [ __ ] stupid [ __ ] violin
lines
so checking with friends or mates
beforehand was exactly what i did oh and
i was trying to be chill about it i was
like yeah no no i just checked with like
a mate and like that but the first day
he did not understand he's he's um he's
austrian-american yeah that's right he's
like with what i'm like with a
with a friend
it was like
yeah i mean i checked with a mate but he
seemed to say that was okay
with him with a friend okay and but but
for some reason it felt really cool to
have like that you know that uh response
from this youtuber [ __ ] guy yeah
so actually like and then i started
getting really curious about okay that
this lovely gentleman over here is
thinking like this about you know
who else is thinking about like what
what is everyone else saying yeah yeah
so like [ __ ] attitude is where the
reason i got back into anime oh [ __ ] man
oh [ __ ] holy [ __ ] yeah yeah and she
[Music]
we started going to conventions and then
i saw that you were gonna be there i was
like yeah
oh i must i must say hello yeah all
right all right i've i've been enjoying
it yeah i've been enjoying the content
and i have it ever since because like
like i remember because we were both
going to control expo and i was like oh
kevin's going and you know when you like
i don't know why right you just you just
you just like bring out this aura of
just like he's a lad
he's a [ __ ] lad
all right that was extrapolated just
from that one clip that's like oh i
checked with the mate and then yeah
check with the what and then
you just see the paddock being like
check with the friends
wrestling [ __ ] face
and i was just like from that one clip i
was like seems like he seems like a
ladder yeah
i of course we met at the first time at
like the bar or something right yeah
it's like yeah yeah yeah yeah fitting
yeah yeah where where where is the more
fitting place than meeting meeting each
other and i i was are you gigging yeah
yeah and it was like i was like prepared
to be like are you kevin oh my god i'm
like a big fan of your work made in the
best was absolutely amazing yeah lo and
behold kevin comes up to me and taps me
on the shoulder yeah and i like like at
this time you know annie i like anichi
was like way smaller than it is now so
like i i'm just like a random guy who
got just like invited to this anime expo
i've been really excited to meet people
in the industry people have actually
worked on anime and then kevin t taps me
on the shoulder and be like are you
gigguk i [ __ ] love your work i'm like
why are you saying this to me
i should be saying this to you it's true
no but that's the thing i came from from
the exact same position right right just
happy to be i'm not happy to meet people
yeah i meant really i mean
because of that show i'm here yeah right
right yeah right we we got to get now i
got like a wee and then yeah it's like
what my mouth was my first time eating
is when you ordered too much chicken so
that was
that's a bonding
well the first time i met you was at an
izakaya in uh in shibuya and that was
and you were just like oh you want a new
long high
and at first i was like who's this bloke
and then i and then i realized it's
[ __ ] kevin i was like oh i gotta take
four magnus
yeah
yeah so of course like crunchyroll expo
we like immediately bonded over [ __ ]
getting pissed as a
british and aussies of course but like i
remember you got to a point of drunkness
where you started like spewing some
really interesting [ __ ] about your
creative process i've made in the
business i did that last night you did
that
yeah
like for some reason there's like a
certain drunkness level where kevin gets
really eloquent about talking about his
creative process and music and he was
talking about this one track which uh
which was played over like a very
spoilerific moment in made in the best
season one it was a very emotional
moment and he was talking about like
using like juxtaposition and like
techniques that he learned from like
universities
university in college and i was just i
remember being like i was pretty toasted
i was just like this is really [ __ ]
interesting i just really like as like
an anime fan i would love to hear this
when i'm sober because i'm like not
remembering anything
so like i i put a mental note to ask him
about it the next day when i'm sober and
so received so we can explain in more
detail it's really [ __ ] interesting
so i go to kevin i was like kevin you
were made talking about this track and
made an abyss and like how you came up
with that and what process you did yeah
like can you like expand that because
that was really [ __ ] interesting and
he just looks at me and goes i have no
idea what the [ __ ] i said mate
no he like kevin kevin did that to me on
friday he went he went off about this
one synthesizer for like two hours
he's like he's like you don't understand
when you put your finger on it it's like
50 springs 50 springs on your finger and
it feels amazing it's amazing
it's like velvety and it feels so good
and i'm just like oh
yeah
imagine putting your finger on um like
you know i'm like diet divers uh like
not skin types
like a wetsuit what diver what yeah so
there's a i got a synthetic made out of
diver wetsuit with all these different
springs underneath and you play it like
a seaboard so you can like you play
synths and stuff but it's like a
leonardo sort of thing all right you
assume i know what a c board
oh yes
imagine a piano but with no keys and
it's just a line
yeah that's that's a seaboard yeah
like
is that the thing that they did like the
[ __ ] jerk it out meme on
imagine that but instead of a pen it's
your finger oh okay yeah this is it
yeah so he was going off about that
right for like what felt like two hours
and it was really interesting but i was
his exact same situation i was like i'm
really happy this is really cool you're
showing me all these like youtube videos
in this like really loud bar and i'm
like having to do this
yeah it's like really like specific
um quite nuanced sound yeah
like i was like oh it's a 43 minute
video just let me scrub for a minute
it's just
yeah but it's good to hear it's like
great when you're hearing someone who's
like so passionate about it yeah yeah
yeah yeah i mean to be fair like
i do actually [ __ ] love it like
i might like joke about it a little bit
oh i don't remember how this [ __ ]
happened but you know it's like it's
like at least like you know as like a
fellow musician i understood majority of
what you were saying i can't imagine
what it was like for god right it's just
like hearing all these like musicology
terms it's just like be like yeah have
you ever heard a moose
i asked about like the doom soundtrack
and you were telling me about how oh
yeah to compose it he got some russian
synth and i was like oh i was like you
were telling me i was like i was like i
was like yeah
yeah in my head i was like i was like i
understand that the it being from russia
could add to the sound of sounding more
dude
yeah yeah i was just like i'm in my head
i'm like does the russia have a lot of
influence on the synth being like more
dooms
like is the soundtrack of russia just
doomed like so so yeah i feel like like
once i tired you out i like went yeah
you were getting the next victim because
we were like sorry let me tell you about
russian synthesizers yeah i was like i
was like i don't know any synthesizer
but i'm open to him um so the polyvox is
a soviet era synthesizer that um it's
it's about 50 kilograms and it has like
the one one of the most gnarly [ __ ]
sounds because you got to think okay the
synthesizer is basically i mean among
other things it's voltage being put
through an oscillator okay so it's like
it's a [ __ ] biblical sound it is
beautiful and the way that you can shape
these oscillators and then filter them
through different effects and stuff
makes a synthesizer's character come out
so like yeah different types of
processing that you have
i mean you can just listen to the
oscillator b and oscillator but at the
same time the way that it's processed
through certain other like kind of
effects and boards in a synthesizer
gives it a certain unique character this
is this is exactly how we sound
by the way
very eloquent yeah like you know in the
same way like you have like a guitar
right and you have different makes of
guitar right different types of guitar
depending on how it's made the pickups
and stuff like that yeah it'll have a
different characteristic yeah think of
it like that but
electricity okay right and so this
particular synthesizer that yeah was was
used in the in the doom soundtrack and i
i would love to get one but like they're
no they're not easy to get you know yeah
it's like they are dated instruments now
yeah that is the thing so is your house
just uh filled with
insurance and synthesizers and a bunch
of other random stuff because i used
yeah so
my [ __ ] i guess call it both a
quarter life crisis and like my pandemic
kind of like
pandemic crisis right right prussian
[ __ ] [ __ ] covert sort of like yeah
outlet was just to fill this room with
just all this [ __ ] [ __ ] to just yeah
yeah and like it's it helped it helped a
lot yeah i mean i saw you tweeting about
it constantly right so i'm like yeah
but like that's the problem is that like
all it took was for me to ask about this
like one one particular synthesizer that
i really liked
all i said was so kevin i heard you
bought a moog and then and then he just
went off for two hours
sorry let me tell you my life story yeah
now we always think like what's the
opposite of you know the horse girl well
apparently it's the synthesizer
[Laughter]
the sims guy i'm still trying to figure
out why i tried to make you think about
what a moose sounds like
i don't know why i picked that
see this is the problem it's like i'm
too sober it's funny
i'm not making enough [ __ ] yeah you're
making enough sense yeah it's like a
little gray area where you get between
like dysfunctional and functional yeah
functional dysfunctional
again why would i just decide
yeah i know everything yeah upside down
is up exactly yeah so i'm a bit afraid
to ask after what we've just talked
about but what is your creative process
do you have one
right
um
because i'm sure you have like the
answer prepared for like when you get
asked that on a panel and like i i hear
you ask uh answer that question on the
panel and i'm just like that that is not
like the kevin
i know so uh yeah um
so it's kind of weird because um because
i don't like
i haven't
he's probably he's buffering
buffering
like that
whatever it's called a deal i was
talking right now
my bad uh
[Laughter]
yeah exactly like it's a one-minute
supercard
he left the end
um
so is it the beeps and the boobs no well
yeah so um
it comes from like it comes from many
places
i can't make that sound good so i'm just
going to meme it but um
so
let's say for example one one way is
that i've um
i've like woken up in the middle of the
night i had like some sort of [ __ ]
weird fever dream but then
up with like some sort of melody in my
head yeah i'll write it down as like
almost like a musical morse code on like
evernote because i got like evernote
yeah i'll do like a little memories like
b dash dash is like b for two beats
sorry like a temper maybe like uh like a
like
tempo you wake up thinking about
melodies some only like sometimes but
then the problem is i'll like write it
down be like oh that's [ __ ] good i'm
gonna go back to sleep now i'm gonna
wake up nice and early after i've had a
nice rest and you know just like get get
to work and i wake up and like oh
it means [ __ ] nothing for me so i
have to like reinterpret what i like
wrote some momentum
because i used to do that as well yeah
and but now now
but now when i do it yeah i just sing
into my phone so the next morning i wake
up and i'm just like it's just like
audio of me just like
it's like really quietly like three in
the morning aki must think i'm [ __ ]
psychotic
because they're singing to myself at
three in the morning yeah i mean but it
helps yeah
i mean
another way that i'd like start a piece
of music would be like let's just try
and like find a cool sound or a call
like
right right so yeah whether it be like
one of the uh
sort of one of the
therapy synthesizers that i decided to
try yeah which synthesizer should i use
today i'm just loading up loading up
logic pro and just being like okay
let's [ __ ] around and just see what
happens yeah that's a little cheeky
little piano sometimes it's nice stop
playing stuff yeah it's just like well
most of it's [ __ ] but then eventually
you get something that's like okay it's
not
too [ __ ] that i couldn't come back and
like refine it later
might be a little bit of a riff or
something sometimes stuff like that but
so like um
let's take uh let's take um
the rising of the shield here main theme
mm-hmm start it's just like sad piano
boom
that's like sad piano yeah yeah yeah but
then you have um
this violin coming coming in going bit a
bit
[Laughter]
i don't remember that in the writing of
the shield hero
no i would be i would be very out of
work
with this nintendo lawyer is knocking at
your door like i was trying to do like
that
what's the melody version
that was where that so i would start
with that and try and work around that
right
i guess you could think of it as like
you know you create like one little line
and then you're creating another line
that kind of connects to that and so it
kind of slowly becomes like a sort of a
bit more of a complicated kind of beast
like patchwork type of thing right yeah
and like you kind of like go back to
like kind of fill in and refine
so like maybe i'll have like a structure
or something i'll have like you know
most of a structure of something
um to work with and then i'll just kind
of sit back and be like okay what sucks
what needs to be changed and just kind
of refine almost like um something like
uh is it trench fishing
what's that
it's it's weird it's where like they are
yeah it's like it's like a nest and then
you gotta drag the seaboard like the
seabed and let's say that fish like that
it's like a filter process
that was the that was the loudest like
five seconds of silence ever on the show
that was like that was the loudest
science ever
i
yeah dredge fishing like you think of
that as like but you're just like going
through you're listening yeah yeah i
don't know
yeah then just kind of refining refining
refining it until you kind of can't find
any more like flaws so to speak right
right right or you run out of time right
yeah do you kind of like do you kind of
like show those like unfinished or like
you know combed through pieces to like
other people to get like a second
opinion or do you kind of just like all
the time
there's like a few
kind of like kind of core people where
i'll be like hey so yes yeah right yeah
just be honest yeah let's just tell me
yeah tell me what's the track in your
row like and you're just like this one's
the banger this one's a [ __ ] bang and
i can't wait to hear this this this this
is the one that will explode my career
i don't think like that i don't think
like that um what what i normally like
more what i gravitate more in terms of
like being confident about a track is
kind of the process of it yeah um here's
an example that i can't tell you like
now but like last night but um like
let's let's take like maiden abyss uh
season one for example right um
there's a track that i mentioned earlier
called swings and roundabouts and it
involves a really cool sort of arpeggio
style playing a playing technique um
called arpeggiation on a violin so
normally when you play violin and i'm
sorry any violence out there about to
[ __ ] hate me because i'm not i'm
gonna explain what a violin does like as
a flawless and it's gonna suck but um if
you think of it because normally you see
a violin they play one or two strings at
the time and then they normally change
their fingers like that um
one of the techniques that i really
enjoyed was where they put fingers in
all four strings and then just kind of
go up and down um on all four strings
right always make like a chord
well if you do like that doesn't do much
but you go one two three four back one
two three four buttons
so it's like this kind of cool kind of
chord sort of thing and and you can play
it quite they play it very very fast
yeah [ __ ] good musicians yeah but
then you can change that all the time so
you know you always like
and you just kind of change your chords
all the time and you can make like this
really cool like because it's a very
shimmery sort of texture
but um i did that on one violin and then
i had
in in the best season one we had three
violins three viola two chelly and one
bass and they're all of them playing
like solo parts so it's like nine songs
right right and they're all playing
these different chords like arpeggiated
chords together and it's called sort of
making this bit of this sort of
cacophony of like sounds and stuff yeah
like doing those sorts of things makes
me feel good about that track it's like
oh i got to explore this kind of crazy
thing
yeah exactly it's like oh i got to like
kind of explore that and it didn't
[ __ ] fail
and it sounds good yeah that was great
yeah and that that and i like the i like
the noise yeah this is so alien to me
that you're explaining all this stuff
and it literally just sounds like
another world like it doesn't sound like
a
thing that i can even comprehend but i
appreciate it because you know i i know
you're making sense yeah it's just like
to me
such engineering and math brain yeah the
way i approach everything and like it's
very like okay i just do it i do there's
nothing that's like just a gut feeling
there's no experimentation yeah yeah you
know
i mean but i mean there needs to be a
part of that in in in this process
because experience means that you can
execute these ideas
i've i've had like crazy [ __ ] ideas i
have no idea how to do and i still don't
yeah i was gonna i was gonna ask well
you said something earlier and i was
like how do you conv so like you said
mention that you're in like a a chapel
or something and you're recording like
yeah orchestra or something right
how do you go like hey hey hey higher
ups um i have this idea yeah i'd like to
rent out a church somewhere in austria
could we ship uh and get a bunch of
violinists and all the people yeah um
yeah it might it might work out let's
just see how it right by the way it's a
hundred thousand dollars yeah yeah
the uh the might part is definitely not
something that i translate yeah
you're liking
yeah a little bit of trust yeah but um
so obviously like when you when you
start a project you're given a budget
right and uh you know the budget you
know sometimes you can like kind of
stretch it a little bit and you know you
can do something a little bit of black
magic just to get some deals it's budget
like
this might sound stupid there's budget
and then you get your pay separate right
that's like completely yeah
[Music]
um
so uh when we were able to kind of like
explore this idea of using made in best
an example like yeah we're trying to
explore this like this massive studio uh
called the synchron stage in vienna
which i think it fits like 135 musicians
it's a massive room yeah like i'm pretty
sure it's like a football field if not
slightly more like i understand that
battery yeah
there we go
like it's got a really unique sound
profile and so you can stick like a
really small amount of musicians in
there and it will sound [ __ ] huge
because they put all these microphones
around you get all these ambient mic
friends they stick with like 30 feet up
in the air and stuff and you have they
called out triggers and you got like
everything man you got all this sound to
play with is that not just like a
nightmare to have to go through all
those different like
angles of sound
to me you're
he sees that mike 30 feet up in the end
he's just bricked up he's like damn
that's gonna sound so good these mice
got me acting up man
you have absolute permission like slit
my throat i don't actually utilize the
space like that like
nuts yeah yeah yeah but like like so the
space is phenomenal and then we get a
small amount of musicians because like
we decided like okay small amount of
characters in the film
in the show a small amount of musicians
to kind of like mimic that that kind of
party size yeah yeah and so just having
like yeah like three solar violins three
solar viola three uh two solar each
other one cellar base but then they're
all kind of doing their own thing but
because the space is so good and so
clean you can have all these voices like
really not if you orchestrate correctly
right you can uh so it's like if you
balance your textures correctly and all
that sort of [ __ ] yeah um you can have
like a really rich sound with a small
amount of people and you sound
phenomenal right
it's beautiful it's really fun
performing magic yeah yeah yeah this
means you just said like so many words
that i'm like
i'm like damn man say that again
because sometimes like i appreciate it
but i mean sometimes like just the basic
stuff like even just doing the bass like
but it is like
kind of let's call it simple like refine
simple right sort of ideas this is
really really fun uh one of the other
tracks that's that's an amber season one
called um recapitulation um
something in recapitulation sorry but i
should probably remember my own tracks
um but it just involves the nine strings
just playing like playing just notes
all they're doing is changing the
duration of the bow hand in order to get
shorter or longer uh shorter or longer
notes
they have like three different levels of
length of node but it's the same note
it's the same note i mean we change up
the chords sometimes but it is quite
minimalistic right
right
but um
so basically
if you change the texture in that room
the um because you have something called
um
uh oh christ i should probably remember
the damn thing from um
what's called
nope we're gonna go
all good man all good um it's like early
reflections early reflections i think
it's called early reflections okay right
right right the early reflections of the
sound so like the sound that kind of
like because
sounds flying everywhere in the room
right yeah
sound goes everywhere and obviously it
bounces off certain certain points and
then comes back to the microphone yeah
those early reflections
early reflections
in that room are really really cool
right and they have a lot of character
because it's almost like an echo effect
effect
and so for example if i recorded your
voice in there but i didn't use like the
mic that's in front of you but i used
the mics that caught like the first
reflections of you just behind you or in
front of you something like that right
it would almost sound like there's like
10 of you right really cool of course
it's quite unique to that i mean because
it's kind of like spread out and bounced
around a little bit right yeah because
of the quality of the quality of the
wood in the room and stuff yeah and
things change
so it is it is like a really good room
so is this like is this place like
famous because i can't imagine okay
you're gonna record a soundtrack you
want like a certain sound profile for
like made in this like because this
place seems like it was tailor-made for
a series like maiden abyss and caverns
and wide open spaces yeah how would you
like go about finding the perfect
recording spot or the perfect space the
correct recording spot yeah yeah the
correct yeah for abyss it was that one
um i think for well because rising of
the shield hero we recorded in boston
with a rock orchestra and they specified
in rock orchestra so the players did
live performances at the time
uh with with a full live band i think
they did some fun fantasy stuff among
other square in his projects among other
things as well right so they like kind
of specialized in that kind of quite
cool kind of attitude orchestra with
rock which which is what we wanted to
achieve here right tower of god um
obviously i mean it's it's in the name
as well it has like a slightly biblical
sort of um
sensibility about it and um we found
this hall in the czech republic called
the dvorak hall
so it's this beautiful old horse built i
think in the name of the borjak uh so
he's like a very very very um famous um
composer
romantic
uh
yeah late romantic music i should say
but um
so this hall was designed either for him
or by him or around him so sorry about
not being specific about it but it is a
beautiful concert hall it is it is
ancient it is it has this beautiful lush
sort of like reverb tail and stuff it is
[ __ ] pretty to like listen to
and it's a performance all but they also
do recording there yeah and uh which so
we recorded string orchestra there for
shower of god because it had this sort
of almost um cathedral-esque sort of
sensibility
which worked great for certain aspects
of the tarragon soundtrack right that's
right concepts right right
so this this one hall it was
they had a very specific sound that say
and you're a normal cathedral wouldn't
i'm sure a normal cathedral would but
that's when practicality comes into it
right make sure at the end of the day
that
um you know
again you gotta you gotta fit within
certain budgets and stuff like that yeah
yeah yeah i mean that's that's part of
like the business skills part of it
which yeah
right so imagine you have these these
grandiose ideas and this this concept
that you have yeah and there's a guy
there that is like i am here to scale
you back down
we're getting real experimental
we're going to build a cathedral in
space yeah
apparently apparently a dying black hole
or like a black hole is like the loudest
sound ever but you can't hear it i
believe yeah yeah i believe probably
yeah
yeah yeah the moon would be nice but i
don't think i'm gonna
you're not gonna make a whole lot of
progress yeah no no i think tell us the
fact about the dying black hole being
the the loudest thing i think they did
manage to record it oh no yeah
i think it is it must be the loudest
sound because it's it's a black hole
consuming stars but yeah they've managed
to record the sound of it i think
recently and it's like just this eerie
[ __ ] yeah it's it's
it's adam's being crushed into nothing
yeah
right right right anyway yeah
interesting
[Laughter]
second loudest is a modern warfare 2
lobby
exactly
so like going like i guess moving from
maine in the best one thing i've noticed
is that you always try to do something
new with like every new project that you
take on i guess that's why you put a lot
of experimental stuff into made in abyss
um and i feel like
tower of god right it's that's just like
dubstep which is like so far removed
from what you were doing and made in the
abyss like how how did that come about
like did you have to listen to like a
lot of dubstep to like study it or do it
would do that just like come on did they
tell you or was that your decision to be
like i'm gonna put a bunch of [ __ ]
dubstep no that's because i used to go
to a lot of [ __ ] raves
i just feel like
no no um like one of the people i worked
with
okay pre-story again but uh
like yeah so perth has like a massive
dumb drum drum basically we've already
get in the background yeah yeah yeah
yeah but we'll pendulum from there for
example oh yeah
of course like he has a great scene and
uh yeah so i when i went to whopper
i got introduced because i was like oh i
love video game music and that's it sort
of thing yeah but then um one of my
friends one of my really really close
best friends that i still you know we're
still really really close today yeah so
we know each other [ __ ] is getting on 13
years now yeah but um yeah he used to be
like oh well we're going to [ __ ] you
know we're going to like this like hotel
bar to go to rave and i've got a track
and one of the dj's is playing one of my
jumpers
and then yeah just do a bunch of [ __ ]
like vodka cruises and whatnot just
sounds like a [ __ ] energizer bunny on
the [ __ ] floor
like for like three or four hours and it
would be great and so i kind of kept
that and when i moved here obviously
that you know this big kind of edm
yeah i just like to imagine you were
like defcon or something and you're just
standing there like they don't know i'm
a florist
[Laughter]
but that that um that culture of um of
dance music and especially um
like hardcore yeah well yeah the liquid
drum bass or dark tone bass [ __ ] just
kept with me
so like
if you think about like kind of those
elements where it's either like very
very fluid sort of synthesizers or that
you can be like it like there is some
[ __ ] hardcore like music like in that
genre yeah yeah yeah if you've like been
to like uh ahmed it's like there's
there's so many like there's so many
like examples but you know if you hear
like um
i can't even think of like i remember
going to a couple of gigs uh in either
south east london when i was living here
yeah and the [ __ ] base that comes out
of some of these like venues yeah yeah
there's like speakers like
i went to this warehouse gig once i
can't remember where it's been so long
ago but now but like i remember like
just walls and walls of spaghetti
meters and then because it's like a
three-story warehouse they've got
something that's going on yeah yeah yeah
yeah [ __ ] base that comes out of
those mixers yeah when you're on the
dance floor you know obviously you had a
couple of your vodka tonics or something
like that man you just like it's it's
wetting it's yeah you you feel you feel
every atom in your body just like shake
it yeah yeah yeah especially the base
like it's a [ __ ] physical reaction
yeah biblical man it's so good yeah yeah
and so like you know the bass is good
when you don't hear it you just feel it
yeah that's such a good adjective yeah
biblical i mean i'm gonna use that more
often
it's resonating your chest
it's really good
it feels awesome and it sounds great as
well
this is the chicken sandwich
it's so good that jesus had to get
involved
there's a little spiritual um but yeah
so um
that culture and that that feeling yeah
yeah um still is with me even though i
write a lot of uh orchestral music as
well yeah it came to when it came to
tower of god um if you look at the manga
because mamawa i'm like manga is um it's
colorized yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
so uh if you look at the color palette
for tower of god in the manwa it's
actually very minimalist so yeah like
three or four like very big bold colors
on yeah on a panel and then you go back
and you so you see these really
interesting like some of the characters
are sometimes just silhouettes against
like a huge beautiful background right
right in front of a giant creature or
something like that so there's a there's
a as a composer it's like kind of a bit
of a wet dream it's really good yeah
yeah so um if you think about taking
really bold colors that are contrasting
and try to put them together in a
musical sense yeah like you can split it
into let's say a frequency range you can
go high mid low yeah so if you have uh i
did a theme for one of the characters
called rachel yeah and her theme is
literally just harp so there's harp in
the middle there's like dial up style
tones on top and then just this bass
comes in to just kind of punch you in
the face essentially right chest cavity
and so like that sort of like dubstep
with heart for example like how can we
find interesting combinations that still
kind of relate back to this idea of
frequency spectrums being kind of split
up to represent very minimalist but
maximalist style coloring and paddles
yeah yeah yeah i think so like you know
you have these kind of pretty heartburn
you know and then they
you know these sorts of um
uh like also radical changes in textures
as well like that suits tara god in my
mind at least yeah yeah no it definitely
did yeah when you when you handed it to
them and you're like here it is they
were like were they like whoa
it was kind of interesting because um we
did essentially what you could call
almost like a concept album we did like
13 tracks we're like we're going to put
together 13 contrasting tracks
yeah but like we did like like the first
13 tracks as like sort of prove the
concept saying like this is what we want
to do this is how i want to do it this
style of choir and you know this happens
dubstep idea and want to you know punch
people in the face with like [ __ ]
like beats and [ __ ]
and uh they were all for it which again
just [ __ ] lucky and yeah thank you to
them for like actually just being like
being cool with it yeah yeah yeah like
when you explain stuff in music i'm like
yeah okay all right
biblical minimalist and then
maximalistic
within like one second and i was like
that sounds like you you know what's up
look into my eyes
i just like i'm trying to i'm like yeah
okay i hope you have questions yeah of
course of course yeah yeah at the end
you also need to you know execute the
concept yeah of course yeah so like you
know because obviously everything's done
kind of in a computer so to speak until
you go to the recording process as well
yeah you're also showing a demo you're
not showing like the full right
realization yeah yeah sort of thing so
then you've got to potentially risk you
know going and finding the right
musician finding the right space yeah
within the right budget of course as
well are you the one handling all of
this is the oh i mean it's not like i've
got um
sort of the music supervisor director
yeah yeah yeah that we we work with
every day right so if you need someone
to play the half right you need someone
to record it you're like i know a guy or
well you're like please find me a half
page well this is the the lucky part
about going to a music college because
you know everybody you get to know a
bunch of musicians yeah so like a couple
of composer friends that i went to
with uh and
so i'm going to come back to it but uh
like you know it it's all [ __ ] it's
all connected man
my man's got to meet you on speed
um yeah so like for example like uh when
i went to undergrad and whooper like i
had a couple of friends and stuff that
like i started working with on tarot
cards so yeah um you know uh matt mclean
feeding here is his name and we did some
jump bass stuff for um for tower of god
yeah yeah like really really nice yeah
and then um
i need some musicians because i went to
yeah the rcm here in london right and
like those those student musicians are
bloody good yeah you know those yeah
musicians of the rcm become
you know they have a very very good
chance of becoming working musicians
yeah
right you'd hope so you know
there is a there is a really like they
are
beautiful musicians and
because you because you're just
basically breaking bread with these guys
for two three four years yeah you're
going to the rcm bar and you're getting
hammered with these guys all the time
and so you know you have like this
connection because you know in the same
way that we kind of you know broke a
little a little bread over yeah over
about 600 gin tonics you know you do the
same with like the music and stuff
they're good friends and but they also
just they just they they come to work so
yeah so it sounds like every aspect of
the entertainment industry it's like
yeah yeah you can be good at what you do
but also you need to go out and talk to
people yeah yeah exactly social media
super important and so um when it came
to certain projects like this like tara
got like oh
i mean valeria was the harp player and
she she does not need classical heart
but she also does improv harp so i can
just give her like you know i could
almost give him some you know really
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] like sheet music
where i was like i've done my best to
like make it so that it doesn't look
like an absolute insult but
feel free to like just interpret this
in a non-shitty way right i was gonna
ask you about this so i was like you're
mentioning that you're the one writing
the sheet music basically
how do you how do you come across the
knowledge of every single instrument you
want to use pain and suffering because
it's like because obviously if you're a
violinist you do violent yeah you're
very good at it like you're like i need
to know this russian synth also can i
find the harp and i need to write that
like this sounds like an overload of
knowledge that you have to acquire or
have a rough understanding of almost
everything
um so um
yeah so when you're orchestrating for a
larger ensemble so harp is a very very
specific and very unique instrument yeah
it works on a pedaling system which um i
understand the concept of but don't know
how to like achieve right so what i
would say is that you're kind of working
up your base knowledge of certain things
right obviously like when i write
woodwind
like woodwind sectionals uh it's it's a
lot kind of
let's call it more natural yeah do you
understand that yeah okay i understand
that if i do something quite [ __ ] that
there's going to be a will or a way to
kind of get it done yeah that's why i
hear like a quite a few flu passes and
whatever so because i you hear a lot of
flute jumping up and down and up and
down and up and down because like ah yep
it's like you you should it's just your
comfort yeah right he's just like but
then when it comes to say to meet you
with violinists because he is such a
[ __ ] boss i can do
like what would normally be insultingly
stupid [ __ ] but he'd be like okay let's
go and just [ __ ] yeah
i can do this
and then he's [ __ ] like does all
these different permutations of it yeah
just do a bunch of texts and just cut it
together it just sounds [ __ ] awesome
yeah and i just sat there like oh [ __ ]
it actually worked yeah and then like so
it's literally like [ __ ]
trial and error i was gonna say
which is basically just going through
yes going through every instrument and
just being like what does and does not
work as you just build it up so flute
but then there's ultraflute base flute
and then yeah basically has certain
characteristics in which you know if you
go too high on the baseline it's going
to start doing overtones right right
right
and the flute or the piglet won't do in
the same way would you say there's
always a concern then when you're like i
don't want this guy to think i'm a
[ __ ] idiot for writing this and then
handing it to your professionals like
that's why i like giving me a chill
atmosphere in the studio okay okay
for example that's why
you see in that in that that's when you
stopped people mates
yeah it's like i like you want to bring
your a game so yeah you come you come
with the like the best possible job that
you could have done yeah you've done as
much research as possible
yeah yeah it's it's i mean because
that's what that's why i gained a lot of
weight in pandemics i was
working but i couldn't do anything like
kind of get rid of the stress because i
was like right right it's like okay i
need to do this and do that and like
like the star wars saying like you know
you want to make sure that is right yeah
yeah of course you want to bring
the best [ __ ] sheet music you want it
to be beautifully type set you want that
to be the best looking music you've ever
written right right
and you want the
musicians to be happy because you want
the project to go really really well
yeah right right thankfully it did but
like again like you bring your a game
and then you give the musician enough
adequate scope if there is a mistake
yeah or you oh you get yourself you know
what it's almost like you're refining
the the level of potential mistake yeah
down to where there's and like you're in
a a sphere of like safety yeah and then
within that if there's a mistake if
there's something like that oh that
dynamic doesn't work that doesn't yeah
well they tell you they'll be like yeah
this this part isn't really doable or
like let's just they should tell you and
that's why it's good to be like hey just
so you know if there is anything wrong
tell me i don't mind yeah
that's why i guess
but that is literally the conversation
and you have that conversation all the
time yeah yeah because like
i don't yeah there are like there are
people that you know it's like okay
we'll go for a take now
okay i think
yeah yeah like that right uh like that's
fine but uh
i guess maybe like my style i'm trying
like myself right now at least is like
yeah i'm just happy to be here and i
just you know i want to make sure i'm
just a mate i'm just amazed i haven't
composed anything yeah yeah
but they keep rehiring
just kill me from being a [ __ ] just
tell them
like just we're going to sit down we're
just going to play it yeah there's any
questions i've you know i've done my
best to make sure that you guys have a
good time yeah yeah and if you do a good
time like i feel like you just because
i was explaining to you this to you last
night as well
um like there's a couple of
thoughts of school about like how many
takes you should do right and
you know in certain countries there'll
be like one two or three or four takes
that you'll do or do a run through and
then they'll be like okay we're done
right and then there's other times where
um there's other types of composers
where you'll basically
like do
like multiple takes even like what would
be considered potentially unnecessary
takes just to get like different kind of
like permutations and certain phrases
right so you can cut together and kind
of do like kind of different things yeah
yeah yeah yeah so um i'm in that second
part i was going to say
you seem like you are really not
economical but at the same time um there
have been like more than capital there's
been countless times where i've been
able to basically
like create a really cool sort of
almost like a combination or like an
amalgamation what am i saying
amalgamation yeah
yeah of like different takes
like you know like oh like
bar 34 beat four
the cello like kind of slipped a little
bit on that one note right and it sounds
a little [ __ ] up but let's cut that in
because i like the [ __ ] up nurse yeah
and go back to like this other take
which is a bit more clean some of that
and then let's bring in this sort of
thing the more you're telling me about
it the more stressed out i'm getting
like what if you know cause if you have
like you said you had uh three of each
uh instrument earlier
what if like one guy's just sick it
doesn't turn up well like that's that's
nothing not a thing it shouldn't be
what if like someone's uh they've got to
fly over the visa gets delayed or
something and it's like oh crap you need
to find another guy like this sounds
like i'm getting stressed out they're
messing all these moving parts if it
makes you feel better they're already
there okay okay they're already there
these guys do that day and night
if there was if there was someone that
was unable to come in because they were
sick or whatever the next person is just
there okay right right right right right
one regular whole product yeah yeah i
mean okay so in that case you'll hire
you're hiring maybe not just a room but
there'll be what's called a fixer an
orchestra will fix it you will help
who is like they organize everything
because
you don't know everyone you really don't
right so you're you're coming into a
situation where you're you're hiring a
service so you're hiring
everything
more times than none i've seen that the
studio and the um like musician hiring
service are one in the same right
they come hand in hand so okay
if you're hired in the studio have you
got musicians no okay use use the person
that fixes all that right
and then i'll say okay well we need x
amount of yeah and we need x amount of
yeah would win this
and then let's say you know someone
doesn't rock up they just make a phone
call and i've seen it happen like it
it's like oh uh something didn't happen
uh can you come in yep great see you in
10 minutes wow right wow right you just
kind of you can tailor the session uh i
i i i
bought like if unless there's a request
for them to use their own conductor i
always get uploading stuff yeah we have
a lot more control i'm a bit control
freaky though right so um i'm sure i'm
sure we all i figured that yeah yeah of
course you all appreciate being very
very anal about control yeah but uh yeah
just like let's say for example like
you're missing a child i'm just using an
example
say the cello you know chalice falls
down and you know
explodes
let's go there yeah yeah
how about that you're about
um
so yeah let's say like chalice is
suddenly you know exposed explosion
snaps out yeah yeah
that was a very good start yeah that was
a firm snap ah do you know why
conducting so you go one two
three
[Laughter]
let's say okay let's quickly switch over
to like a different um
let's switch over to like just
viola yeah yeah only trying for like 10
minutes okay let's record that great
finish that welcome back chalice let's
go back to that okay
right right right right
working through it yeah you work in
tandem with what's called a session
producer which is basically someone in
the booth if it's not you like the
composer can produce their own session
if they are hiring a conductor to
conduct yeah but if you've decided to
conduct yourself you work in tandem with
the producer or maybe two producers in
the booth saying yep we've got that take
no don't be a psychopath about that move
on please sort of thing because
you can get in your own head especially
yeah yeah exactly okay yeah actually i
remember you saying like have you got it
haven't got it like in a video when
you're talking about how you have to i
think you were on the scene like it's
like the boys club or something like
that and you were talking about how you
you're doing takes or interviews and
stuff yeah and they're like have we got
it do we need to go again
uh what would be the word nervousness
about okay do we actually have the
content yeah we do not have the content
do we need to go again and that yeah
yeah right but it's important yeah yeah
but if you're filming it and you're also
you know in the shot yeah then you've
got to go back and you've got to go back
yeah yeah yeah
but if but having someone behind the
camera or in this case in the recording
booth yeah saying no we got it it's
chill let's move on yeah that kind of
moves to greece like nice reinforcements
right yeah
yeah it's like i guess the
they i mean they should but like the
cameraman he's like getting the shot but
he doesn't necessarily give a [ __ ] if it
doesn't look great sometimes it depends
okay i would avoid that yeah i would
recommend yeah and it's also sometimes
you they don't know what kind of shot
that you want yeah as like normally
there's with a director they don't have
as much investment as like say someone
you hire to be invested like that yeah
well i mean if you're hiring a session
producer they should right so
you're hiring someone who's like is his
job is to be as invested as you right
yeah so but obviously not everyone will
be because otherwise he's just a guy at
the booth yeah yeah yeah no i do see
where you're coming from now so
there are times when someone is just
saying okay have we got the you know the
standard they'll be like yeah yeah yeah
we got it right you go back and you're
like you didn't have it yeah but then
that would be hopefully where you could
that would maybe the way experience
kicks in and you're saying yeah yeah no
we're gonna go again yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah at the end of the day you kind of
drive the train
right people are really supporting you
people are there doing their job but
right between you and maybe like the
music supervisor or something like that
you guys are driving that train yeah
you've got to be like on it and yeah
this is where
it's not just a physical job it's also
super mental yeah because you've got to
focus on not only if you're especially
conducting you've got the physicality of
making sure okay cue that person in keep
on going like that yeah you come in you
come in b3
you're cueing people even though yeah
but
you know
through the physical act of conducting
it's not just about keeping tempo which
to be fair everyone's got to click in
the air yeah really matter too much but
what it's about is coaching more
performance out of it yeah more it's
actually more
like like you're basically just like
micro managing yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
hopefully like in a positive way right
yeah yeah yeah but it's like for example
if i'm going like this to you i'm like
okay sing things
sing and then yeah okay on that last one
that is like sing more yeah right
again
because that like sounds a bit
constipated but at the same time it's
like okay that should hopefully coax a
little bit more you know yeah push a
little harder yeah so if you're if
you're doing that at the same time
you're also listening to everyone else
in in your headphones
[Music]
making sure that everyone else is
playing it so god yeah so you're doing
that over and over again for nine hours
a day yeah so like you take everything
you just described
how much how many more layers of
difficulty has been has been added on
with kovid i was gonna ask this and uh
having to do things remotely that sounds
like a nightmare in person yeah yeah um
yeah there's a reason that if you see me
like in the room i'm like a sweaty mess
because it is like super intensive
um in the in this like in the covered
times
uh it's been interesting because
depending on where you are it's actually
a little more convenient in terms of the
time difference because obviously it's
like so far in front of everywhere so
yeah um if you're recording in america
it's quite nice because you you know
it's sort of like an early morning thing
and i became a bit of an early riser
journey covered yeah
but um
in europe it's kind of interesting we
did a lot of recording in prague
some budapest
doing pandemic and uh for an upcoming
project we did a little recording in
america as well right um yeah uh
normally for um
for europe it's normally like an
australian nighttime sort of recording
so yeah yeah you kind of sit down at
like seven eight o'clock at night and
then you do six seven hours so you kind
of finish like two three o'clock in the
morning so you're on call yeah with
people who are just in a big hall yeah
so basically just stream the audio on
audio movers and zoom wow yeah it's
actually to be honest like it's actually
not bad really yeah but but what if it
like lags halfway through like a
recording right yeah
yeah because it's like a [ __ ] classic
australian internet just crashes yeah
yeah i was about to say it must be [ __ ]
yeah because yeah
it's like oh kevin's connecting yeah
yeah
that was what was really nice about like
going back to sydney for a couple of
projects sorry going back to sydney
going to send me a couple of projects uh
because like yeah melvin said he's like
an hour and a half on the plane and
stuff right that's pretty cool but um
yeah to finally get back to conducting
for uh for star wars was really cool
because that was the first time i've
done it i
i forgot
the like because the muscles just like
just like go away
yeah because like try doing this yeah
for like nine hours right yeah yeah it's
very like just the right
is
[Laughter]
nah it's like um sorry uh
yeah i forgot how like physically
intensive it was so
like because um because what you
normally meant to do is like maybe be a
little bit reserved in like moving your
arms
yeah like quite a few hours jesus yeah
yeah it's a little interesting sounds
really intense yeah so like speaking of
oh sorry i don't know i have nothing to
say
[Laughter]
i was literally told for an hour and a
half i was like that was all just bands
bro like they're just talking about yeah
that was really literally talking to you
talking to like an anime composer
composed of some of the biggest shows in
like the past few years i literally have
nothing about you to say
yes
so star wars yeah how was how was that
like really cool
how did like
how was it when like the news came in to
be like uh can you compose a piece of
like music for star wars media because
i'm assuming like
great honor
you know obviously it has the history of
history yeah um and just to be able to
kind of obviously so star wars visions
is uh an animated um series based in the
universe star wars and i did one of
those one of those um episodes
did the the episode four called uh
village bride right and um
what i really liked about it is that um
star wars visions uh our episode
explored like some really cool like
spiritual um and uh biblical shuffles
i was waiting for that word yeah
it explored some really nice concepts
with the force uh which was just i mean
i grew up watching that yeah yeah you
watched the original trilogy with my dad
and then then my dad and i watched the
the prequels and then they did watch the
sequels as well of course but um yeah it
was it was really
uh it was really nice to sort of have
like one hand in like sort of that
aesthetic world at the same time we're
exploring
uh certain like spiritual aspects
especially considering like the the
backdrop is is um it's very like sort of
kyoto-esque yeah yeah yeah so like to
have um
to have like the ability to use like
traditional japanese instruments so we
use uh sho we use
uh and so we recorded those in tokyo
recorded um orchestra in sydney put them
all together uh but especially
especially that the uh the show is is a
how is that show is the mouth organ
it's a it's it's a
i mean i'm i'm very very oversimplifying
to say that i've never heard of this
yeah yeah i know yeah i know
and then when kevin said it's a mouth
organ i was this close to being like no
it's not
so you blow into a small like a giant
amount a sort of like giant amount
thanks kevin giant amount giant a large
amount a large amount of um
bamboo pipes
you've definitely seen it before right
yeah
it's part of a temple culture a lot
never know
yeah
i mean you would have heard it we've
actually heard it but um
it's like 12 to 14 sort of um uh
individual little pipes right into it
you can blow it in and and like blow in
and out right uh to create uh
sort of a very very yeah this thing this
thing have you seen this thing
oh i've seen that yeah yeah
yeah i have seen this yeah yeah so it's
a very complex very beautiful sort of uh
cluster of notes that create a very very
dense very specific chord and all these
chords are very very very special
meaning so first off obviously you know
as an australian you i really really
wanted to be very careful about that and
you know that there's been um i mean
there's always a bit of an attitude in
australia when it comes to
uh using um australia's indigenous
instruments which is uh you
you that you don't want to [ __ ] this up
you don't want to be that person that
has really disrespected a very very
important and very sacred instrument
yeah and so that mentality i've carried
like i've been lucky enough to use
uh like sort of australian instruments
in the past and it's always been in very
um explicit collaboration with um first
nations people and using those
instruments because i'm not going to use
that instrument on my own
yeah necessary i don't they i i can't do
that yeah and so
even though i am australian uh i would i
want to make sure that when it comes to
japan's instruments it's the exact same
approach yeah yeah very very like
calculated in a good way like sort of
you know talk to the musician saying
what is okay what isn't okay what are
you happy with are you not happy with
what is natural what is unnatural those
sorts of things what do you have
thankfully like the musician especially
the show player um is phenomenal yeah
and was very very very open to just sort
of discussing okay what does and doesn't
work these are the chords i see these
are sort of like the um the core chords
yeah that you can't like that that you
know come on like the
yeah it has like different systems it's
very very interesting so you um
it it basically you you have like
different combinations of notes that
um they have like a different kanji and
it works actually on the circle it works
on a not a pendulum sorry but like a
circle of fifths type of thing yeah but
not first circle of chords but then all
of them have different meanings and
stuff like that
um i really hope i'm not bastardizing us
as well but like i would i wouldn't know
no no
probably i know
no no but um
basically what happens is that we did a
lot of work shopping and just said okay
how do we make sure that like is this
good this is okay it's right okay right
and when sort of thing yeah is that like
sorry because excuse me it's on this
you're saying like is that good as in
like
if you were to use it incorrectly it
would be disrespectful
well it might not like i don't know but
the problem is i don't know right right
and i'd rather like you don't want to
overstep the boundary just in case yeah
i'd rather ask too many questions and
just like yeah yeah right
to be just said no don't worry about it
it's great yeah don't worry about it but
that's not my permission to give yeah
yeah once i've received it then i feel
okay let's now that now we can record
now we can actually you know work with
these instruments and obviously like
being commissioned to do something which
is anime obviously star wars as well but
like
doing something that is anime yeah um
and in this case has a very specific
relationship to uh japan and its
instruments that's super important for
me to make sure that like you know i get
that right yeah i don't wanna yeah i
don't wanna i don't wanna [ __ ] it up
yeah of course
yeah is it is it is there ever like a
a
difficulty when you're working on a
property
that has had so much history and and
previous works that you could kind of
get lost in inspiration with yeah i mean
yeah it's not it's it's not an easy one
right yeah
it starts a lot of music right yeah yeah
yeah there's a lot of the best music
yeah
because i guess you're just like
naturally going to be compared to the
likes of like john williams right that's
like
yeah but you don't want to sound too
much like that yeah right yeah it's like
because you have listened to it yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah but um like
i mean thankfully because it's animated
actually
it actually because it's not live action
you actually we almost in a way had a
little bit more freedom yeah because we
were trying something new and that was
one of the ethos
[Music]
that was one of the um sort of the the
core sort of yeah yeah um concepts of of
the show was to you know obviously be in
the universe but then to explore it in
this in in a medium that you know i've
been not only lucky enough to be part of
but i really do genuinely love it yeah
yeah
yeah it's important yeah yeah cause like
i remember like watching that episode
and i was like of course i've got to
support my boy kevin i'm going to watch
star wars visions and i remember like
going to this episode and i was just
like this is like definitely star wars
but this is like such a kevin style
and like i don't know like i'm not like
well-versed enough and like musical
lingo to be able to like break down what
makes it like kevin star wars it just
felt like a kevin star wars like kevin
take on the star wars
you know universe and just you know the
iconic music as well is that something
you do unconsciously like you have a
kind of a signature almost to your music
that's a good question i'm not actually
even sure like you know i think
regardless of whether you like aim to do
it or not i think you've achieved it
like yeah yeah yeah yeah do you think
that when people listen to your music
without knowing you'd like or they have
heard from your previous works they can
identify yeah another one of your work
yeah because actually i didn't even know
that you did the music for that episode
but as soon as like the episode started
playing i'm like this is kevin i i
know i know my boy yeah um i might i may
gravitate towards certain cluster
courses but
yeah
i don't know like um
i like i
i wouldn't know how to put my finger on
it yeah i wouldn't know how to do that
but um
i think in a way like it's both a very
endearing thing to hear and at the same
time i'm like okay how could i how could
i knock it here how could i not
necessarily
do that
surprise for the [ __ ]
how can i do it next year so it's almost
like looks like it's a great thing to
hear and i am happy to hear that at the
same time like okay i will i do
eventually want to like it sounds a bit
[ __ ] wanky but like i want to evolve
yeah yeah of course kind of try to
transcend that that's too far yeah
yeah i mean because
as as i we were mentioning before i i
just turned 30 and so i've started like
putting together like a list of okay
what do i want to do in like the next
10 years like what am i going to do
between 30 and 40. and one of them is
like just to like i want to learn to
sing again because i used to sing and i
used to not be totally [ __ ] at it and
now i just i know i sound like pretty
sure like if like get out of practice
yeah let's just say if like the cat was
angry and screeched it would still sound
better than
like singing and i want to like kind of
try a few different musical ideas i want
would be really nice to do like a
personal album
first time like i've never really
released like like a personal album like
this music
it's been in like for the last you know
as far as i can remember like in terms
of my professional life it's always been
to a project which is [ __ ] awesome
but at the same time i feel like you
know what in the next 10 years it'll be
good to like really create something
like that's just you yeah yeah yeah me i
got to figure out what that is as well
because like i don't i don't know what i
am welcome to being in your 30s mother
okay
you know that's really respectable
though like i think as you know because
all of us right now are in kind of the
creative field regardless of if it's
different types of creative feels like i
think we can all you know kind of you
know empathize with that like feeling
right like yeah you know you want to
get yourself out there and try and
spread your wings out as much as
possible creatively right i mean look
how much you've grown as well like look
at your channel and look at your content
how it's developed i don't know all
three of you [ __ ] sake i mean like
look at this podcast i mean last time we
caught up
it didn't exist and now it is this your
personal channels as well we watch them
all the time and it's like we watch the
old content watch the new stuff it's
it's i mean all of it's great but it is
so so lovely to see how it has changed
in the world yeah likewise man likewise
thank you likewise with your stuff
yeah gentlemen all men strive for gold
in their life right gold medals gold
watches gold everything however there is
a certain type of man that goes the
extra mile in life he walks with the
confidence of an eagle and giggles in
the face of danger he's big hairless and
a winning machine and when he unzips his
pants he sees
platinum that's right manscape would
like to introduce to you their biggest
most ultimateest
package the platinum package 4.0 join
the four million men worldwide who trust
manscape by going to manscape.com for 20
off plus free shipping with code trash
taste the manscape brand new platinum
package 4.0 is the biggest bundle
they've ever offered giving you a bulk
discount on manscape's top product that
includes the lawnmower 4.0 of course the
weed whacker two-in-one shampoo and
conditioner deodorant the crop preserver
and also the crop reviver and
anti-chafing boxes so if you want 20 off
and you want to get free shipping use
our coupon code trashtaste manscape.com
that's 20 off plus free shipping by
using our coupon code trashtaste
manscape.com back to the episode so i
guess while we wrap this up i gotta ask
like what do you want to explore next
because you you always say you want to
do something new what's like something
that you haven't done yet that you want
to do
like musically speaking yeah like
musically speaking or just i was gonna
mean for a second yeah
good burger king book yeah
we don't we don't talk about the
impossible here
to go to the source
um
well yeah i mentioned like the personal
album thing i think what i want to do is
uh expand which is the best way to
describe it i think right um
like
you know i'm
i don't mean this in any sort of like
shitty braggadocious sort of way i am
very happy with what i've been able to
achieve so far i've turned 30 like these
wonderful projects i've met wonderful
people part of a wonderful sort of
industry and community
um you know i've got friends and family
and all sorts like i'm i'm i'm good i'm
i'm a happy boy yeah um i think balance
if anything is what i want to achieve
next yeah i feel like you know the next
is like you know it's been like
the pandemic can go suck a massive fat
bag of donkey dicks yeah [ __ ] suck
like but it put a lot of statements
it did put a lot of things in
perspective because like you know you
could work hard and hard and hard and
that's fine for a while eventually like
you know not only does your body tell
you like you you know you've got to take
better care of yourself yeah like i was
mentioning i think maybe off camera but
like yeah put on a [ __ ] load of
weight yeah yeah rank too much ate too
much in the pandemic and like it was
just a way to deal and find we all kind
of get it it's not healthy you weren't
the only one
i don't feel like i'm like yeah i'm not
breaking anything so you didn't watch
i think the statement's gonna come as a
massive shock that was a [ __ ] down
during the pandemic right yeah i'm very
not
very not unique to that
i was not the happy all the time um so
yeah i think the one thing that i've you
know coming into quote unquote endemic
endodemic which is endemic
is that is that a thing now it's an
aussie thing no it's called optimism
[ __ ] optimism so yeah i'm optimistically
calling it endemic and i'm calling that
because like i'm sat here now i'm on the
show that's not that's not that's not an
aussie thing that's like kevin
it's like let it be so yeah
um
but like i'm i'm really keen to like
just kind of
get life back and just feel [ __ ] as
normal as best as possible like you know
i want
like the day to day to be really
productive at the same time like i want
like i live in melbourne now i moved
back to melbourne because i really
wanted to be closer to community and
family yeah and i missed [ __ ] me i miss
australia so much when i was living here
and that's why i moved back yeah uh but
um you know melbourne's like a beautiful
city to be and even though we had all
these crazy lockdown stuff like i'm
really happy there it's a beautiful base
but it is nice to just [ __ ] off and go
to japan and go to america and go to
london and come to london i should say
yeah yeah like so you know that almost
is like it's it's such a pleasure to be
here right now because it is a bit of a
recharge and people still i mean there
are some countries that still can't do
that and that yeah that you know you so
you got to really take it you know you
got to really think that that's that's
right now pretty pretty lucky in the
context of the fact that we are going
through a [ __ ] pandemic
yeah yeah yeah so yeah balance is what i
want to achieve yeah between you know
lifestyle friends professionality yeah
um work ethic uh work quality as well
like yeah i don't know how the you know
it'd be nice to potentially go back to
school like not like school school but
like you know i've tried to learn in
korean a little bit and still trying
that
yeah i've had to
kind of you know
pick my battles in terms of
trying to like learn more stuff right
yeah i like the idea of just trying to
expand a little bit and try out things
try a little bit of streaming uh uh in
like uh mid 2020 or like late 2020
2021 i kind of like put it on the back
burner because i just got
really really busy with you know some of
these projects yeah yeah yeah yeah um
i didn't miss that yeah yeah
it's good fun um
you know just like live composing or
like playing old games like you know
yeah i played like like i want i want to
play metroid prime if it comes out hell
yeah hell yeah yeah yeah playing um eco
on stream that was really really fun
yeah i want to play the colossus
like that's a fun thing to experience
all games that have amazing music
you know just like playing games that
like really important to me on stream or
like composing music in front of a live
audience that it almost like activates a
different part of the brain yeah yeah
um actually i guess you could relate to
like content creation offline and online
right right live i should say yeah um so
yeah expansion expansion and balance i
think is uh yeah
expansion
such as yeah i'm british
i will the expand yeah i mean
like we've wanted to have you on since
basically like the beginning of the
podcast
like who is would be the most perfect
guest for a show like this
the mate
kevin i have kevin
bad things
i can commit and we've had like sorbonne
and chicken
oh [ __ ] boneless man come on yes come
on yes
dude i'm sorry it's my boy you have
korean fried chicken you want bone
chicken or do you want like a [ __ ]
beautiful this is like you know what
it's been a fantastic episode
we're all born together
look i appreciate that you've um come to
terms a little bit better on bread
i do respect that you are getting better
just as a person
um i'm just saying that uh what what do
you want to achieve in your 30s uh and
why is it boneless
i want to uh
expand
the expansion world of domination
what can i say man yeah i mean like like
yeah it's we we've like had to i guess
like [ __ ] move mountains to get you
one because we're not filming in
australia we're not filming in japan
we're filming in [ __ ] the uk yeah you
know which one neither of us even live
in
it's a weird detour yeah yeah yeah
it's it's a it's a weed we're detour but
it's nice that we are able to make this
happen finally absolutely and hey
like hopefully like when japan decides
not to yeah please please come here
please come back because we've gone two
hours and somehow we've not talked about
oolong high long time we're not going to
by the way yeah that's that's that's the
next time that's the next time this is
the sober conversation
this is like the pre-convert yeah yeah
next time you come on the second episode
is going to be ooh
yeah this is the thing it's like this is
almost like this is a season one
this is this is the conversation we
should have had in the old studio yeah
now i'm gonna come to the new studio
yeah let's just get [ __ ] hammered
yeah yeah we've done one chord
1.5 more alcohol oh yeah
but uh yeah i guess uh we'll leave it
there for the time being uh you know
obviously we're gonna get you back
eventually yeah in japan
with a little bit more booze and a
little bit more bands yeah but um yeah
but hey in the meantime try not to talk
about [ __ ] synthesizers for like
three hours
we've only talked about which ones i get
between now and then yeah
yeah well we'll hear your top 10
synthesizers pretty soon i've got a list
i've
but hey look at all these patrons though
these amazing lovely patrons look at
them look at them they're just floating
by oh my god so many other pictures
but uh hey if you'd like to support the
show then go over to our patreon
patreon.com also follow us on twitter
send us some memes on the subreddit and
if you hate our face listen to us on
spotify and hey go check out kev stuff
uh wait dude is there anything you want
to shout out but i do the twitter's uh
and obviously like made the best coming
up uh in uh july i'm so [ __ ] possible
oh yeah we didn't talk about mate in the
biscuits yeah yeah
maybe next time maybe next time it'll be
out by the hopefully like next time we
like you hang out so we can finally talk
about it in depth so yeah we've got a
couple of things going but uh most of
them yeah it's like think of it as like
there's like a like a little pinpoint on
your head with a sniper rifle at the end
of it and yeah you're just like oh i'm
going to talk about yeah
it just doesn't happen yeah i'm not
ready to be depressed
[Laughter]
well uh yeah thanks for coming on kev my
pleasure thank you to all and uh on the
final note i just want to say thank you
to all three of you both personally and
uh you know
it's it's been nice
what a [ __ ] lad is our boy
thank you for doing what you're doing
yeah of course likewise
thank you for helping both of us through
this because it's been a really bad
pandemic yeah it's it's nice to this oh
sorry i don't know
i'm sorry
oh
but seriously thank you for doing what
you do it really helps it's really nice
every saturday to come like wake up and
oh watch this days it's lovely to see
your content
thank you for for doing what you do
because it doesn't matter
i'm just happy that i'm going to hang
out again man i'm sorry
[ __ ] happy can i please have a drink
[Music]
you